the Real Housewives of Beverly Hills is
back season ten does that feel why about
it season 10 well you know it's my fifth
season yeah yes and to think that Kyle
started a decade ago yeah and that
people are still watching and I think
honestly season 10 is probably gonna be
one of the best seasons if not the best
why do you think that well there's a lot
of interesting things that happen and I
don't think we've ever seen conflict
like this ooh I love that
so obviously fans get attached to you
your life the rest of the cast members
but it is a lot about the drama and
based on the trailer that we've seen for
season 10 seems like there's going to be
a lot of that so what kind of drama can
we predict well it's um it's it's a new
type of conflict because I don't think
we've ever seen anything like this
before yeah and it's not just the Denise
Brandi thing it's all of us so we're all
involved in different ways and there's
lots of things that lead up to this
though and there's a lot to look at this
season there's a lot of life stuff on
and you know women together that have
opinions yeah and you guys go to Rome
which was beautiful and I was so excited
you know I was so thrilled to go to Rome
which is one of my favorite cities in
the whole world and it lammer us and
it's fun and then you know the wheels
come off and you guys have never been
all together to Rome before right no no
no there are some better travelers than
others no everyone in this group is
really well-traveled so world yeah this
is there's a group of pros yeah exactly
oh not to interrupt you but Joey lived
in Italy for many years so she speaks
fluent Italian so it was great to happen
yeah it was it's really cool because she
was like translating and you know
chatting and yeah was yeah so you
mention a little bit about the Denise
Brandi drama so we'll fans get to see
that unfold a little bit this season yes
they will
okay and and was that something you were
looking forward to exploring for
yourself just being on this season
like you could do with that well I think
there's a certain amount of conflict
that comes with every season and it's
gonna be played out people have to judge
for themselves yeah would you say that
this season especially amongst you guys
it has a bit of a different time now
that Lisa is no longer than in this
season yeah of course I mean I think
when someone exits there's always a
shift in energy up to we have Garcelle
who's a great new housewife and Sutton
who is a friend of and you get to see
those relationships flourish yeah well
that's exciting um you've had a really
busy year so far you also made your
Broadway debut in Chicago what was that
experience like it was great I'm it's a
it's a privilege to be able to do a show
like that to be on Broadway period yeah
who's such a role like Roxy which is
iconic in Chicago which was the longest
running American musical until it shuts
down I mean it's something that I'll
always treasure yeah and is that
something that was always a goal for you
in terms of doing Broadway well I think
it's a goal of many performers you know
it's kind of the ultimate you know
singing and dancing and acting I mean
you're out there every night eight shows
a week doing it yeah that yeah the
stamina alone required for a show I
thought it's very tough I mean it takes
a lot out of you
you really have and you have one day off
a week so you really have to manage your
downtime and you pretty much you know
your life revolves around show yeah and
speaking of downtime many of us are at
home we're staying at home we're with
our families how has life been like for
you during this kind of crazy time in
quarantine well truthfully it's been
quite an adjustment I'm used to working
a lot that I had shot four months of
housewives and then for my Broadway and
then it came to a screeching halt so
it's been quiet
I needed the brain obviously it was it's
nice to have the break but I wish we're
under better circumstances
it's it's you know challenging to be
inspired right now honestly
I know that we should all be like you
know we're gonna really make the most at
this time but to be really truthful I
haven't been that inspired yeah it
are you staying away from the news or
you glued to the TV or are you watching
shows movies like how are you getting
through this time the news plays in my
house 24 hours a day I'm on television
still not getting away from it I mean
like everybody else I you know watch
Tiger King I'm not yeah it gives you a
lot of time to do a lot of things that
you would not have done yeah do you stay
in touch with the ladies during this
time or do you shoot the show and then
everyone takes a break no we are in
touch we have a season to promote we're
all fully invested we think that we've
made a great show yeah you know I'm
hoping that the audience feels the same
way
yeah and because there's so many fans of
this show with et Canada so many people
who you know we love just talking about
the drama and you guys I have had a
request to ask you if you are creating
any new music or if we can expect any
music from you well I was planning on
that until so that kind of put a little
pause on my career process yes I had all
these plans to come home from Broadway
and go right into this stuff but that's
gonna have to wait for a second yeah
well very happy that we'll be able to
get your show back in our lives because
we just all need to get invested in your
lives and just kind of escape what's
happening sometimes you know well I
think that's the whole point of a show
like you know house is is to escape its
entertainment and you know have a good
time
awesome well thanks so much for call
with me really appreciate it my pleasure
take care and enjoy the season